the North remembers we know no king but
a king in the North whose name is stark
I don't care if he's a busted that
starts blood rose to his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight and Game Theory's video
today I want to talk about why the names
of Daenerys Targaryen dragons are very
important and I also want to point out
some possible foreshadowing from the
books the main reason why I wanted to
talk about this is because of the fans
reaction to the death of us Ariane
during the episode beyond the wall I'm
sure most of you are already aware that
many people were pissed off about this
scene and I have even seen some comments
of people saying the night king will not
kill this Ariane in the books which
could be true because as of right now
there is no night king in the books or
at least he hasn't been revealed yet
however there are a few quotes in the
books that I think are hinting at
vissarion's fate I believe that the
names of each dragon could be just as
important as the names of each direwolf
because it could be an indication as to
what will eventually happen to each one
of them so far in the television show
only one dragon has died which was Miss
Ariane this was the dragon that was
named after Daenerys Targaryen Zolder
power-hungry brother named Viserys we
all remember what a prick Viserys was in
the very first season he sold an error
so he could acquire an army for himself
to try and take back the Iron Throne for
House Targaryen
well the Sarris never received that army
and he began to grow increasingly
impatient which eventually led to him
threatening to kill his own pregnant
sister Daenerys and I think you can all
guess what happened next
called Drogo decided to award his new
king by giving him his own crown early
before he was even seated on the Iron
Throne the part of molten gold killed
Viserys and now the dragon that was
named after him is dead - the night King
currently has control of a serie and he
used him to bring down the wall at
eastwatch-by-the-sea now it's only a
matter of time before Daenerys and
Viserys are reunited and I think we can
expect to see vissarion turn on Daenerys
and rogue on just like her brother
Viserys did before he died the dragon
that Daenerys currently rides his drug
on who is named after her late husband
called Drogo that's pretty
self-explanatory Daenerys is third
dragon Ragle is named after her other
brother Rhaegar Targaryen who also
happens to be Jon Snow's father I'm sure
most of you know this already but for a
very long time people believe
in the prophecy that Rhaegar made
popular which is the dragon has three
heads fans assumed this meant that all
of Danish dragons would have their own
Targaryen riders Daenerys would
obviously ride rogue on but who would
ride the other two was still up for
debate the most well-known theory states
that John would ride regal and Tyrion
would ride with sari on mostly because
people also believe Tyrion is a
Targaryen the show did give a hint at
this back in season six when Tyrion was
able to bond with the Dragons but that
was completely thrown out the window
when the knight King brought down
Viserion now it doesn't look like Tyrion
will ever ride a dragon but there is
still a chance for Jon Snow to ride a
dragon the television show has confirmed
he is a Targaryen and the only other
dragon Daenerys has was named after
John's father so it would make sense for
him to ride regal plus we have also seen
Jon begin to bond with the Dragons I
would actually love of Jon was able to
mount Ragle because not only would he
then have his own dragon but he also has
his own dire wolf how many characters in
the history of this universe can say
they've had both I can't think of any
the reason why I wanted to bring this
prophecy up is because it's still open
for business in the books as of right
now in the books Daenerys still has all
three of her dragons but there may be
some evidence that is foreshadowing the
death of a dragon which would explain
why the show chose to kill this area on
first let's take a look at some of the
quotes from the books because I know
some people don't believe Vissarion or
any other dragons will die in the books
the first quote I want to show you as a
conversation Daenerys is having with
Jorah Mormont and what's interesting
about this conversation is Daenerys is
actually asking about a dragon's
lifespan Daenerys says well how long
does a dragon live then at that exact
moment she looks up and sees vissarion's
swooping low over the ship his wings
beating slowly and stirring the lint
sails
surger Mormont shrugs his shoulders then
says a dragon's natural span of days is
as many times as long as a man's or so
the songs whatever's believed but the
Dragons the Seven Kingdoms knew best
were those of House Targaryen they were
bred for war and in war they died it is
no easy thing to slay a dragon but it
can be done
Daenerys is concerned for the safety of
her children like any mother would be
she wants to know how long dragons can
live and which dragons name did the
author choose to write neck
as they were having this conversation
Daenerys notices Vasari on as Jorah
Mormont is telling her dragons are hard
to kill but it can be done this could be
indicating vissarion will also die in
the books but this one quote by itself
could just be a coincidence so let's
take a look at another one when Daenerys
walks outside onto the terrace she
notices ragle asleep beside the pool a
green and bronze coil basking in the Sun
Jurgen was perched up atop the pyramid
in the place where the huge bronze harpy
had stood before she had commanded it to
be pulled down he spread his wings than
he spied her there was no sign of a sari
on but when she went to the parapet and
scanned the horizon she saw pale wings
in the far distance sweeping above the
river he is hunting they grow bolder
every day yet it still made her anxious
when they flew too far away one day one
of them may not return she thought so as
you can see in this quote Daenerys is
getting anxious because Viserion is
flying too far away then this has
followed up by her thinking one day one
of them may not return I think we can
all guess what's Dragon that will be we
all know how important the names of the
direwolves ended up becoming and like I
said earlier I think the same thing can
be said for the Dragons all three of the
narces dragons are named after men that
are dead that could be seen as a nice
tribute or could be seen as a red flag
that they're all destined to die before
Daenerys many people believe that in
order for Westeros to restore some sort
of balance we will have to see magic
come to an end which would mean the
Dragons must die and Viserion was always
meant to die first during Game of
Thrones season 7 they certainly went
above and beyond to let us know her
dragons are not invincible and this has
been proven throughout Westeros is
history during the Targaryen Civil War
known as the dance of dragons multiple
dragons were either wounded or killed by
scorpions and crossbows dream fire was
blinded by a bolt that ultimately led to
her death storm cloud was fatally
wounded by a scorpion shot to the chest
and during the first Dornish war MARAC
--ss a beloved dragon of Aegon the
conquerer was almost instantly killed by
taking an iron bolt straight through the
eye this would not be the first time a
man was capable of killing a dragon but
more often than not dragons are
typically killed by another
now that we have fire dragons and an ice
dragon I think it's safe to say we could
see some dragon on dragon action next
season we should see at least two major
battles next season one battle against
Cersei and another one against the night
king considering this as the last season
we may see more bloodshed in season
eight than we've ever seen before and
both sides when it killed Daenerys as
dragons
we have seen just how easy it is for the
night king to kill a dragon but we also
know Cersei has been preparing to kill
her dragons as well now that Danny's
dragons are entering all-out Wars it's
only a matter of time before they start
dropping like flies
they foreshadowed this over multiple
episodes last season it began with
Cersei and Qyburn revealing they have
been making plans to deal with the
Dragons
she has three full-grown dragons Yogesh
same as Aegon when he conquered the
Seven Kingdoms how do you propose to
stop them
we are currently at work on a solution
my lord
then again in the very next episode
Circe says this about her dragons i
decapitated the Dornish snake my Armada
owned the Narrow Sea
Yulin Greyjoy's our moderns there's some
great Joe is loyal to me for now
Daenerys Targaryen has three full-grown
dragons how well do wooden ships fare
against fire-breathing dragons her
dragons might not be as in barnable as
something in their same episode
Qyburn then shows Cersei exactly what
he's been working on and he says this
powerful but not invincible
apparently one of the nearest dragons
was wounded by Spears in the fighting
pits of Meereen they can be wounded they
can be killed right before the big
parlay seen in the dragon pit there is
another scene but this is when Tyrion
says they will show up with two armies
and three dragons but we all know what
happens to one of those dragons later in
this episode nobody trusts my sister
less than I do believe me but if we go
to the capital we'll go with two armies
who'll go with three dragons anyone
touches you King's Landing burns down
the death of a dragon was built up over
the course of the entire season we knew
they could be taken out of the sky when
bran hey drug on with the ballista the
pressure continued to build and build
with each passing episode until finally
it punked then down goes Vissarion the
night king killed the first dragon and
Cersei already knows Daenerys lost a
dragon she had already had enough
motivation to want to kill her dragons
but now she has the confidence that it
can be done most of them will die I
finished them in the field we can't beat
them we can't beat the Dragons
how many dragons did you see the dead -
what happened - the fall we know it's
guarding a fleet she came here with her
dragons and heads off
honey she came here to show us all her
power something happened we knew Qyburn
had one ballista made but I'm 100%
confident we will see more than one
ballista in King's Landing next season I
also think Qyburn may start putting
poison on the tips of the errors as well
but I will talk about that shortly the
first dragon that obviously needs dealt
with is Vasari oh now that he's under
control of the night King John and
Daenerys just left the King's Landing
area and they are now heading to
Winterfell
the night king is heading south with
Vasari Owen and he will most likely pass
right through or near Winterfell as he
advances so it's pretty obvious John and
Daenerys what to take care of the night
king first the night king currently
poses the biggest threat to the realm
and he's getting closer with every
passing minute Viserion already died
once but now he will have to be killed
for good I know there are a number of
different predictions about how to kill
Viserion because I've actually made a
video about that myself if you've seen
that video then you know I think drogon
ends up killing Viserion I mostly base
this on the dragons names and also
because dragons usually kill other
dragons drogon was named after Danny's
husband called Drogo and Viserion was
named after Danny's brother Viserys
called Drogo killed Viserys in season
one and I think drug on will kill Vasari
on
in the final season but there is
something I want to add there is a very
good chance dragon and/or regal are
badly injured during the great war
against the night king i do things are
going will kill Vissarion but that
doesn't mean vissarion won't hurt or
maybe even kill one of Danny's other
dragons before he's taken down
permanently I think this will be what
ultimately pushes John into riding Ragle
John knows how vulnerable the dragons
are when they don't have a rider
directing them and he already feels
guilty about Daenerys losing one of her
dragons while coming to save him so I
think John could mountain wriggle during
this great battle now if magic does come
to an end and all the magical elements
of the show start to die out I think
drogon could be the next dragon to go if
you read the books you will see that
Rhaegar was frequently referred to as
the last dragon it was basically a
nickname and as we all know Danny's
dragon Ragle was named after Rhaegar the
last dragon so he could possibly be the
last dragon to survive or at least the
last one to be killed off I should say
let's think about Khal Drogo for a
minute what ultimately led to his demise
was a small cut on his shoulder he got
way too cocky during his fight just like
Oberyn Martell and it led to his death
the wound on his shoulder ended up
becoming infected which probably
poisoned his blood then marry master
does her witchcraft and call Drogo is
basically a zombie now think about what
happened what drug on in season seven he
was shot by an arrow from a ballista and
where did it hit him right in the
shoulder just like Khal Drogo who he was
named after obviously the injury Gurgaon
sustained during the field of fire is
not going to kill him but that doesn't
mean he won't die shortly after this
anyway now I'm not saying the arrow bran
used was dipped in poison or anything
like that however I think Qyburn could
start doing this in the future that way
the next time they get a shot off on one
of Danny's dragons it does bring him
down for good I'm sure Jaime told Cersei
and Qyburn what happened during the
field of fire so they should know
they're ballista is effective but it
wasn't quite enough to finish him off
unless you would get lucky enough to hit
him in the eye or rip through the heart
but the chances of that happening are
very slim I do want to point out there
are at least two different ways you can
look at this you could say call Jirga
was killed due to the infection but what
actually killed him for good was when
Daenerys put him out of his misery now
think of how heartbreaking it would be
at Daenerys was put in this position
again but this time would drag on who
she considers her child this is just the
kind of thing I could see Game of
Thrones doing to us in the end
Daenerys might live and she might even
have a healthy baby with Jon Snow but
they could add one more gut-wrenching
moment by having Daenerys put drag on
out of his misery everything would come
full circle
drogon would kill vissarion just like
Khal Drogo killed by Cerys in the first
season
then Daenerys would end up having to put
Drogo out of his misery just like
Daenerys had to do what called Drogo in
the first season it would almost be
poetic in an extremely sad kind of way
but in order for this to play out
something would have to happen a drag on
that would cause Daenerys to want to
kill him
well Qyburn could poison the arrows they
use for their ballistas when Daenerys
inevitably comes to take King's Landing
or the night Cain could severely injure
or kill and turned rogue on - if drug on
ended up being poisoned
to the point
that he became extremely sick and
clinging to life like Khal Drogo then I
could see the nurse wanting to put him
down to ease his suffering if the night
king killed him and turned him into an
ice dragon as well
then Daenerys would have to do something
about that obviously or else the night
king would kill everyone else I'm not
sure if all Danny's dragons will die but
I personally think she will lose at
least one more plus Viserion also has to
die for good this time I've always felt
like Jorgen would die at some point he
has been one of the main attractions
since his birth some would even say that
all of Danny's dragons have to die in
the end because it's too much power for
one person to have the Dragons make the
system unbalanced because they are the
equivalent of nuclear weapons and
everyone says this is supposed to be an
anti-war story so I could see the most
powerful weapons including all magic in
general being wiped out of existence in
order for things to be restored to some
sort of balance now I actually enjoy the
magical elements in this show and I
would hate to see Daenerys lose all of
our dragons especially drogon because
they has such a special connection to
one another but I also can't ignore the
fact that them dying is a very good
possibility let me know your thoughts on
all of this what do you believe will
happen to the dragons by the end of the
show put your comments down below I'm
curious to see what some of you have to
say I want to thank all of you for
watching the video I appreciate that
very much and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel I hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you